green
is Olympics and a helicopter group
continue
and many more more
of the war and
uh
every person
foreign
thank you very much
thank you
thank you for this
so many people
leading three millions
[Music]
it is
25.
my address
create in
and divided it from a man to the world
Canada
[Music]
Securities
needs to be amenities
crisis
foreign
[Music]
sanctions
[Music]
did the time the Free World uses to to
think
Ukraine enemies
[Music]
we pray
the world was
allowed
into where Russians
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
consciousness
[Music]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
three years ago was my first time
around the world
now the world is fighting against
three years
foreign
stress
the history
repeats itself
assassinism
the butterfly
and the next
difference to planetary changes
[Music]
will overcome again
disease
sorry
[Applause]
[Applause]
Mr President thank you thank you so much
so much
Ukraine
in November December
18th for another
stalemate
right now
thank you for the question you know
you know thank you for your condolences
too
how it looks
it looks as follows
the east of our country
unfortunately lost for The Bravery
it's very important um
foreign
[Music]
to support us this year
get this Revenge
civilized approach towards life thank
you
um yesterday today
foreign
[Music]
is to see the different political
leaders and figures those who are still
very relevant so have been relevant
until recently for them to be able to
recognize the greatest Putin committed
for them to recognize this is Russia's
aggression
these moments it is very important for
them as well to politically pressure on
Russia to stop this
regards
we clearly understand that security
guarantees priorities for us
priorities
doesn't understand this as well and they
do their template us
make it easier for us but we are on the
way towards later because later is the
best security guarantee foreign
I was going to support our proposals
finally finally Mr President the the
accident uh the helicopter
crashes
in my mind
the question of your own safety
um do you do you feel that there are
still ongoing active threats
your Social Security every every day
no I'm not worried about that
I don't have anything to add here
[Applause]
uh right
now
nothing has changed we still need
ammunition I'm not in case to anything
to anywhere
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
let me invite our panel up we have
really one of the most extraordinary
panels Christian Freeland the Deputy
Prime Minister of Canada Jan stoltenberg
the Secretary General of NATO president
Duda of Poland and the Director of
National Intelligence of the United
States Avril Haynes please come up
let me begin
Avril Haynes with you if I may American
intelligence these days is uh is uh